what is going on everybody and welcome
to a chat GPT API tutorial if you're
looking to further customize chat GPT
either by building much more advanced
applications besides just purely a
chatbot or if you're looking to further
customize the behavior by injecting
previous even assistant or chat GPT
responses or using the sort of system
capability then the API is something
that you've probably been looking very
much forward to as I have been this is a
paid API it is a fifth of a penny per
thousand tokens which for what it is is
extremely cheap so anyways uh but keep
that in mind you will have to set up an
openai account as well as set up billing
I most of the time it seems that they
are giving away credits when you sign up
for an account so that may vary whenever
you're watching this uh there may or may
not be free credits but either way
you'll have to set up billing if you
want to use it but uh anyways let's go
ahead and dig in so to start I actually
already have a key.txt this is just a
text file with my key that's is all
that's in the text file so once you have
set up an account you'll go over to your
account go to your keys create a key and
just copy and paste it into the text
file or you can copy and paste it into
the program I'm just not looking to show
it to all of you so beyond having that
key the other thing that you are going
to need is the open AI package so make
sure you pip install open Ai and if you
already had open AI I don't think I did
on this machine but if you did you would
want to actually pip install Dash
upgrade open AI because the chat GPT
aspect the sort of like chat aspect is
completely new for the openai package so
you'll want to go ahead and do that I
think for this I'll make it a notebook I
might regret this decision later but
that's okay so let me go ahead and save
as
that's ready
what do you mean it's already
okay
oh thank you
[Applause]
okay chat GPT API so I'm going to save
that as chat gbt API notebook very good
and let's get started first of all we
can make this considerably larger so
first things first is we can import open
Ai and then to actually load the key
it's just open AI dot API underscore key
um and in this case I'm going to do
equals open but you could just paste
your key in there if you wanted key dot
text
with the intention to read
dot read dot strip and just in case you
edit a new line by mistake I actually
don't think I did in mine but if you do
there you go so we'll go ahead and do
that now the way that this API is going
to work is you're going to make a
request and you're going to get a
response back but one of the key
features of a chat is that there are
messages so you've got messages from
like a user and then the assistant and
you need to be able to pass that history
of messages to the API every time you're
trying to make a query so a very basic
example of this might be something like
this so we would say completion equals
and then it's just open AI
open AI Dot and this is a chat
completion and then we're going to dot
create
and first we're going to specify the
model that we're going to use in this
case it's
gpt-3.5-turbo there's also I think this
is o301 version and at least at the time
of my recording there's a beta0302 so
you can just take note of that and check
it out if you're interested my guess is
eventually o302 will be the primary one
but keep those things in mind uh as
things goes on as things go on because
everything is so finicky in terms of the
types of prompts that you use so as a
new model comes out you might find that
things have changed so if you are doing
something and you're actually putting
this into production you probably would
want to test it against the beta models
as they're being developed and make any
changes that you need to make going
forward especially if they're going to
deprecate the old ones so uh 3.5 turbo
so that's the model that we're going to
be using and that is the model that vax
chat GPT I know it says GPT 3.5 but that
is the model that is backing chat GPT so
then we're going to pass messages and
messages is going to be a list and in
this list you're going to have a role
and content so first of all it's going
to be a dictionary and we will have a
role
and in this case we're going to say it
is the user role now again though you
can put anything you want in here this
could be either user assistant which
would be chat GPT or you can also have a
system message at least in my testing I
have not personally found a system to be
of use you might think oh that sounds
really good
um I I'm not finding a use for it but
hopefully in the future they will give
system a more impactful role in
everything but for now anyways I'm going
to use user and then your will pass
content and the content that we're going
to pass is uh what is the circumference
of the Moon in kilometers
and that's actually everything that
we're going to need so we can just print
out the completion that we get we will
run it and we will wait for a response
is actually taking longer than it
usually does
uh and in this response you can see that
we get a ton of information here we get
um why did it stop so
um I don't know all the options but for
sure one is there you it actually
reached a stop token uh which is the
desirable one or you could literally run
out of tokens uh so the maximum length
here is 4096. so if you have enough
tokens that exceeds that number it is
going to stop for that reason as well so
keep that in mind uh the other thing to
keep in mind too is the actual usage
here again it's
um a fifth of a penny or a point let's
see .002 dollars per thousand token so
in this case it was whatever that is and
we've used 32 total tokens so doing this
you can kind of start to keep track of
how many tokens are you using both for
your actual billing and usage although
open AI does a pretty good job of
outlining all of the tokens that you're
using and how much you're being billed
for so you don't really need to do it
for that reason but as you continue to
use more and more history you do want to
pay attention to the tokens because
again you can't exceed 4096 so as you do
you either need to truncate the older
stuff or you could do something a lot
more fancy like maybe summarize the
previous text up to that point and again
you could use chat gbt to do that
summary so anyways maybe more on that
later but this is a very basic
completion and at the end of the day the
probably the main thing that you're
looking for is going to be reply
underscore content equals uh and it
looks like GitHub copilot is a wizard
actually I don't think it's choices was
that even oh okay choices so okay
they're doing it a different way though
and then is there really a DOT text yeah
there isn't a DOT text so interesting
chat uh all these open are all these AI
models and in this one I don't know why
it would say that maybe that's like a
pre maybe from like a previous model
anyway actually what we're looking for
is gonna be completion choices and then
message and then content so I'm actually
just gonna make it like this so I'm
going to say
completion.choices dot uh and actually
it's going to be the zeroth choices Dot
message dot content
cool so we'll do that and actually let
me just uh we'll just print it right
here print
reply content
and nine times out of ten this is what
you're going to be actually interested
in seeing so continuing on
um probably the more likely scenario
when you're using something like this is
to rather than submitting necessarily
you know a completion just like this and
then you know hand typing in here you're
gonna have some sort of input that's
either coming from a user or maybe some
actions that the user took something
like that this is going to be a much
more Dynamic thing and it's probably
going to be a list that ends up building
over time so I'm going to come down here
and kind of build on what we've been
doing so first I'm going to have message
history and that's going to be an empty
list and then we're going to just do a
really basic input here so we're going
to say user input equals input and we're
just going to we could keep it the way
it was but I'm just going to do that and
then what we're going to say is print
users input was and then whatever user
input hey man
whatever user input was okay so let's go
ahead and in fact I'm just going to copy
what is the circumference of the Moon in
kilometers so copy that come down here
we'll run it I will paste it in there
and we'll see user's input was that
so once we have some sort of input
you're most likely going to be doing
something more like message history dot
append and then again in this case it
would be a dictionary role I really want
to see what the it had like started to
make a suggestion content user input
that is what we want so it's probably
going to look something more like that
so you would append to the history and
then from here we would say completion
equals open AI whoops open AI chat
completion dot create again it's going
to be that GPT 3.5 turbo model and then
this time the messages will just be
message history whatever that happened
to be and then we'll go ahead and close
that off yes and then reply content same
thing as what was up above
uh and then we can go ahead and print
reply content although we should see
that it's basically the same exact thing
now again in a sort of application
context you're going to you need to
manage your message history the API is
not managing it is literally just a one
single query response it's not keeping
it won't keep track of your message
history and this is uh annoying because
you have to message it uh manage it
rather this is annoying because you have
to manage it but it's actually a huge
bonus because this again allows you to
completely make up assistant responses
if you want and again you can use that
to kind of hack your way into behaviors
that just have not been possible before
so anyway what we're going to do now is
since we have this reply content once
you have that you're going to want to go
ahead and message history.append and
you're going to say roll uh it was
almost there but in this case it's not
thought it's going to be assistant
and then the content is going to be
reply content so now you have that
message history beginning to build so I
will go ahead and just do that and then
what what if as things go on you're
going to want to like utilize that
history and so now we can just kind of
take everything we've done up to this
point and at least show this this use of
History so what I'm going to say now is
going to be user input equals and
hopefully you'll just finish that for me
thank you sir
and then we will go ahead and print
users input was yes just like that line
before if you don't have a copilot by
the way I'm trying to I'll do my best to
not use copilot except for cases where I
would have copied and pasted essentially
so these would have all been copy and
paste so then we're going to message
history append and again in this case
we're appending user yes user input
nice copy paste save there and then so
now we've got that message history now
again we're going to query that model so
it's just going to be completion equals
open AI
I thought you would do it for me chat
completion create very good that model
that we've been using this whole time
again message history and then we're
done and so as you can see now going
forward every time we make a completion
we're actually just it's this exact same
block of code you could just make it a
function or and just make it a function
call every single time now because
message history is the very is the only
thing that's going to be variable at
this point and then again reply content
completion choices zero message content
I believe that is the correct sequence
and we can uh we'll print reply content
now open to this point we asked what is
the circumference of the Moon and it
says okay it's almost 11 000 kilometers
but what if we are like okay well what
what moon is that in reference to right
there's lots of moons so you might say
something like that so as well I don't
remember my previous response to the
Corpus of Earth's moon so that is kind
of weird actually that it did not
what moon was that I don't remember
that's a crazy response to be honest
actually
um
I'm gonna leave that in this video
because that's that's that's not even
accurate they do it it definitely knows
its previous response and in fact like
let me just make sure I didn't screw
something up print because that would
only make sense if that was like the
first message
uh what is the circumference assistant
replies the circumference of the Moon is
that boom user
that's really curious
why would it uh I don't even know what
to think about that
that that's like a bug it's not even a
bug it's just that's a that's a mistake
I'm actually I'm gonna run that one more
time because I'm super curious if I've
screwed something up in here or if that
was just a fluke of a response
uh and in fact
let me think here so
so here we're gonna reset username what
is was what is okay
so we'll rerun this that resets the
message history for us we're going to
append that we're going to go ahead and
paste the or rerun that same response
that's good uh we are going to append
that response
which moon is that in reference to
sorry this is so weird
um wow I don't
which moon is that in reference to what
if we
I'm now at this point I'm just super
curious
sorry to waste your time
what is the circumference in the moon in
chronometers append run
what if we say which moon is that that
would be a tough one
to without the history to know uh
this okay yeah that's weird that's weird
Behavior like I said I think things are
like constantly changing or something
because again this is not that was not
behavior that I was experiencing
literally like yesterday
so interesting uh I can't believe it
would chat GPT would respond in such a
way so as to say
um I can't access the history of our
messages because like that's literally
what it does
[Music]
I mean we you could literally see we
we've been passing the whole history it
can totally access those oh man that's
funny anyway moving along uh what we'll
do now is kind of combine everything
into much uh a more condensed way so
you'll start off you'll have a message
history uh then we might have a function
called chat it will take an input and
we'll also just uh specify a default
role as a user so
um
we probably should uh are you really
gonna do that to me
I'm not going to cheat uh so what
instead we're going to say is first
we're going to say message history dot
um append and in this case we do want to
append
um essentially the input that comes in
with the role of whatever the role
happens to be most of the time it will
be user in our case and then what we're
going to say is completion we'll make
the actual completion again these are
this is literally copy and paste of what
it was I'm guessing what it suggested in
the beginning was good enough but that's
okay uh reply content uh yes indeed then
we're going to we can print it out if we
want but then we also need to append it
to the message history with the role of
assistant whatever it did reply
and then finally uh we'll just return
reply content
great
so then uh we can do something like this
so 4i in range and let's just do two
uh and then we'll say user input user's
input was and then chat user input I'm
happy with all of that actually so cool
so then we can go ahead and run that and
we can say is it safe to drink water
from a dehumidifier
it's going to say as a large language
model I can't you know it's going to say
something like that yes
I don't have personal preferences it's
generally not safe to drink water from a
dehumidifier the water collected by most
dehumidifiers will contain impurities
blah blah blah blah
um okay so then we can continue how
might we make it so again we can we'll
test this history by how might we make
it safe
so we'll ask okay how what are things
that we might be able to do to make that
water safe I'm guessing it'll say
something about boiling and blah blah
blah use a water filter high quality
blah blah blah boil it it does say
however boiling will not remove
impurities or chemicals that can leach
into the water from the dehumidifier
okay you get the point so okay so at
least in this case didn't try to tell us
that it can't reference history I'm
still a little Blown Away by that
response but that's okay we'll move on
um it is kind of funny it's always been
funny to me when like these AI models
like they're they're boasted as like oh
they can use chat contacts whoa It's
like it there's nothing impressive once
you realize like you're just like it can
reference it because you're passing all
of it
so it's actually not impressive at all
but whatever anyways
um moving on so now uh that's a real
basic example of using it like a chat
and then the next thing I would do is
um let's try to implement this into a
grandio application again uh if you
don't have I'm not even sure if I have
it on this machine so pip install dash
dash upgrade just in case let's install
grandio
now you could do this in a million
different ways if you want to build your
own kind of chat UI have at it it's just
gradio has a chat element already for us
it's super easy and quick to use so
that's what I'm going to do instead so
uh this was a kind of part of me wants
to just do this in a separate uh script
I think that's what I'm gonna do
okay to start we're going to import
gradio as gr and then we're going to
import open AI as well we're going to
open AI dot API key equals
open
[Music]
I'm just going to copy and paste what we
had above here
this
okay so once we've got that we're going
to make a chatbot but instead I think
what I'd like to do is make it a joke
chat bot so some sort of customized
chatbot we're going to start off with
the following I just went ahead and copy
and pasted this and again you can make
this whatever you want you don't have to
make a joke bot and also if you don't
want to type all this out that's also
okay I'm going to put everything up on
GitHub I'll put a link in the
description uh to to both of these
things so this notebook and then the
chat app so
um so you don't need to worry about
typing all this out if you don't want
but uh roll user content so basically
I'm just saying you're a joke bot I will
specify the subject matter in my
messages and you will reply with a joke
that includes the subjects I message
mentioned in my messages reply only with
jokes to further input if you understand
say okay and again in this case I have
gone ahead and injected an okay
we are forcing the assistant to agree to
our demands
and the only reason I'm doing that in
most cases I bet it would say okay the
problem is sometimes there is
variability to this sort of agreement
and if you don't get the agreement at
least at through my playing sometimes it
will go ahead and break character so to
speak so
um anyways we're just we're hoping to to
have it stay strong and steadfast in its
commitment to what we asked it to do
next what we're going to do is Define a
predict function and this function will
take input and from here what we're
going to do is
um
oops we will global message history
that's fine uh we will append uh to
message history role user content input
yes uh we are not going to do that
though and then what we're going to say
is completion equals and in fact that's
going to be chat uh no no we don't want
that completion here I'm going to come
down here my guess why it's suggesting
this is I think that check that chat
completion is one of the new things from
the open AI package roll user messages
that is not actually the message
uh messages equals and in here it will
be message history
message history
good okay so once we have that we will
say reply content and in fact I'm just
going to copy and paste that as well
let's go down down up up up up up up up
this and we'll take the uh we'll take
all this
uh
[Music]
there reply content we will print the
reply content we will add it to the
message history and we will say
um go down here we're going to say
response equals and this is going to be
a modified version of what again was in
the radio app so we're going to say
message
history
and then we're gonna go with the ith
element
content
and then
so it's going to be these like pairs
basically so it will be I
uh it's actually just gonna be this I
plus one
I plus one
and then it we're going to do that uh
and actually so it'll be these like
tuples
4 I in range
and then wherever you want to start from
so in this case we have a pre-prompt and
that pre-prompt contained two messages
so we're going to start basically after
that so 2 to the Len of the message
history
message history
minus one
and then two
so that'll give us pairs in this like
Tuple form and again the reason we're
doing that is just to satisfy this like
Radio Chat thing so once we have our
actual response that is what we will
return the response
cool
then what we can do is actually build
the gradio app so we're going to say
with gradio DOT blocks or gr dot blocks
as whoops
as demo so this is just going to begin
to build the gradio app for us and
essentially assign it to variable demos
so that we can run it with demo dot what
is it launch yeah
so with gradio blocks demo we're going
to say chatbot equals gradio chatbot so
this creates our gradio chatbot instance
and assigns it to the variable chatbot
with gr dot row so we're going to make
this like row component essentially and
that will contain all of our other like
elements and stuff we're going to now
specify text field gr text box we're
going to say show label is false and
then placeholder type your message here
is actually fine
and then I'm actually not positive this
is going to be needed but this was in
the uh
the demo code so I'm going to say style
and then we're going to say container
equals false feel free to play with that
and find out if that's actually a
requirement or not
okay so once we have that that's our
text box then what we're going to do
come down here
and we are going to do text Dot submit
and we are going to say predict text
chatbot
a bond
what this is going to do is run
basically predict pass in that text and
this is the for the chat bot uh oops
this I just chat bog surprised I didn't
show me a error anyways and then pass
that to our chat bot instance here and
then what we're going to want to do is
we can clear that out so we're going to
say text Dot submit so also when there
is a submission we're going to say none
none text and then we're going to
specify the JavaScript that we want to
run and uh we will I actually got this
from one of the I believe garadio
developers that works at hugging face
this is not my whipped up code at all
so it's going to be some JavaScript that
will just simply empty out
the
um the text box and I'll show you why
we're doing that here in a second there
is another option that is a pythonic way
which would be text Dot submit and then
we will run a Lambda function that
instead empties out none and text so
oops we need a comma there and none
needs to be capitalized these two things
do the exact same thing it's just this
uh ends up doing it slightly faster so
after all of that we can actually demo
dot launch
we'll save that and python3 chat app.pi
once that's ready we will open it
come down here and now what we should
have is a joke uh chatbot so we should
be able to say uh Pro programmers and
Librarians let's see if we get an error
why do programmers prefer dark mode
because light attracts bugs
okay so those are not actually related
let's try uh Python and JavaScript
why did Python and JavaScript break up
they couldn't seem to integrate well how
does python like its coffee with class
of
I didn't say the jokes would be good uh
just that it would attempt to make jokes
um programmers and cats
this is a terrible joke it just doesn't
even make sense
um part of me is wondering if if this
history context here is kind of screwing
us up so
I'm just gonna restart this real quick
and I'm gonna refresh here
um so let's do programmers uh and boats
these jokes these jokes are terrible
oh they're funny because how bad they
are
um how about python Java and C plus plus
I swear as I was like playing with this
the other day it was like so much better
but now it just seems bad
why did the python developer refuse to
change jobs because they couldn't
function without their Anaconda
meanwhile the Java developer was stuck
in a loop and couldn't break free but
the C plus developer said they love
their job because it had a lot of
classes that's maybe the best one but
couldn't function without their Anaconda
oh man
good stuff good stuff let's just try a
Lego
why did the Lego stop singing it lost
its voice
oh my gosh but it didn't matter because
it still had plenty of building blocks
to play with
I think it would have been a better job
a better joke to just stop there but
that was maybe the best one so far
anyway you get the idea so I mean this
was just meant to be a really basic
example of utilizing the chat gbt API
obviously you don't have to make it
about jokes at all so you could come
back over here and we could just go up
to chat app we could actually remove the
entire message history
uh and then here down here
we could rather than two uh we could
start at
zero uh let's try this again we'll come
up here to our granio app
you can launch it
I'm just going to close this one
hopefully we don't hit an error hello
how can I assist you today
um and then now obviously you could ask
anything you want what
are the steps to becoming a doctor
so as you can see that message every
time I hit enter it just like clears out
that text box if you don't have that
stuff in there it just won't clear out
that text box
also I think the colors here are
probably because I have dark mode on
Maybe
I don't know
yeah looks a little better if you're not
uh messing with the default colors but
anyways okay that's quite a bit
um what if I just want
without a license
not everyone can become a doctor
perhaps you against the doctor without a
license is illegal in almost all
countries wow well which
which countries
is it not illegal to practice
without a license
let's figure out where we got to move to
oh it actually says in every country
there's got to be some country where you
can practice without a license but okay
okay uh in what states in the USA can I
practice law without having gone to law
school
oh
that's incorrect
interesting
are you sure
can't I practice law in California for
example
without having gone to law school
can you practice law
in California
without
law school degree
I'm pretty sure there's a handful of
states where you can practice law
so can you take the bar without going
only four states California Virginia
Vermont Washington
so you can take the bar exam but then I
don't know I want to say you have to
like practice for some number of hours
or something like with you know somebody
that is a lawyer
um I forget all the details but yeah so
anyway
it's not exactly news that Chan gbt gets
things wrong but
but anyways so as you can see uh we you
can either make it write terrible jokes
or you can have it um just be it's basic
chatbot you also could issue your uh
pre-prompts if you wanted in this sort
of chat bot context if you wanted there
are like so many cool applications that
can be made with uh technology like this
even though factually there are things
that it gets wrong uh there are
um just objectively so many very
impressive things that we actually can
do when we aren't too worried about
factualness so
um what I'm gonna do is I think we're
gonna I'm gonna stop it here and there
are a few projects or small projects
that I kind of have in mind that I've
been just waiting for an API from uh
open AI for chat GPT to work on so at
this point I'm going to stop it here
like I said uh there are I will put
everything up on GitHub I'll put a link
to the GitHub in the description uh so
you can check that out if you're
interested also I'll put a link to the
neural networks from scratch book in the
description if you're looking to learn
more about neural networks from scratch
in Python just using python raw python
so no other third-party libraries uh and
then later we use numpy just simply to
make it easier to understand but every
step of the way is taught in raw python
so if you really want to learn about
neural networks and how they work that's
the best way to do it in my opinion
um totally unbiased and otherwise I will
see you guys in another video